welcome to sidetrack this is your sci-fi
tv and movie channel
so who are the most dangerous bad guys
in all of sci-fi
here's our top four first of all we've
got to think about marvel
and we're going to think thanos he
obviously wiped out half of the galaxy
for a bit at least but the reason why he
makes a list is not just because of the
death toll
but because he actually doesn't believe
he's the bad guy he believes he's doing
the right thing and to be honest you can
logically argue
if you remove all compassion out of the
equation that he is actually doing the
right thing
the whole speech with gamora when he
tells her about her homeworld and how
now it's a paradise
where no child goes to bed hungry
really underlines and emphasizes that
maybe he's got a point in the most
recent what-if episodes that thanos is a
good guy he's teamed up with a new
star-lord
the black panther
and in that he keeps telling people his
plan and everybody's like sounds a bit
like genocide is that no it's not
genocide because it's random it's not
evil i'm not doing it because i want to
it's not personal i'm doing it because
it's for the greater good
and sometimes
just sometimes
for the greater good
do we have to do something evil
but because he actually believes he's
doing what is right and he is 110
committed to his course
makes him very
very dangerous
emperor palpatine from star wars
he obviously led the empire into
building two of the most destructive
weapon systems the universe had ever
seen
the death stars
and then built in
random achilles heels in both
one an exhaust port still don't quite
know the torpedoes went in and down when
there's an exhaust that comes out and
out but anyway space wizards
just built a nice big millennium falcon
size hole right through the middle but
we'll ignore that
these were both incredibly powerful
weapons weapons capable of destroying
and he did destroy entire planets
but he's made this list not because of
his two death stars no he's made the
list because of the fleet of star
destroyers he built
in rise of skywalker the fleet of zeiss
on star destroyed he had hundreds of
them and each one was capable of
destroying a planet these axiom super
lasers were capable of destroying whole
worlds and he had literally hundreds of
them one of the things that's really
going to mark out the the really evil on
this list is the desire to use those
weapons he didn't care how many people
died as long as he got what he wanted
and that makes him an incredibly
dangerous character
in star trek we have some incredibly
powerful beings
for example the q in theory if you
believe the q and what they say they're
capable of they could click us all out
of existence
however they don't actually have the
desire to do it so they're not
particularly dangerous to the
wider universe they're only really
dangerous to picard and janeway when one
of them are bored
but there are creatures in star trek
that are incredibly dangerous and none
more so than the borg
one reason we know they're probably the
most dangerous species in our galaxy
is that when q wanted to teach picard a
lesson he clicked his fingers and sent
them straight to the borg
you want to be out here you think you're
ready
have a look at this
that to me says the queue knew exactly
what the ball got
he knew exactly how dangerous the board
are
and there's another episode in voyager
where he very very clearly tells his son
cue jr don't provoke the borg
even the q might be a little bit afraid
of them
but why are they on the list they very
nearly assimilated earth twice
it's not that they have the desire to
kill they don't really their motivation
is not about killing it's about
assimilating it's about power it's about
control it's about gathering new
technologies
it's about an ideal of perfection a very
twisted idea of perfection
but the one thing that we see over and
over again about the borg is a
relentlessness
we see other species that have stood up
against them successfully defeated them
but the board kept coming
and coming and coming
wearing down their defenses
learning from each attack
developing new strategies new weapons
and eventually overtaking almost any
threat
except for species 8472 we have seen
nobody stand up clearly against the borg
when the federation did the first time
was viewed pure luck
and the second time was basically
because of picard
given enough time
the borg are more than capable of
assimilating the entire galaxy
the most dangerous bad guy on my list
is anubis from stargate
stargate sg1 had some great bad guys in
it the goal being
right up there
they are evil but mainly they're
incredibly selfish and if you've got a
gold that even the system lords think is
too evil for them then you know you've
got somebody that's seriously psycho and
that's what we had in anubis they
expelled him they tried to murder him
because they thought what he wanted to
do what he did was actually unspeakable
he was too evil for the most evil
now there were other bad guys in sg-1
that nearly matched
the ori were incredibly powerful but
they didn't necessarily want to kill
they wanted to be worshipped the
replicators they were relentless but
again their desire wasn't to murder they
were trying to gather new resources
gather new technologies and learn when
we saw the nano
robots they weren't really evil but
anubis was
he's quoted as saying i'm not really a
bad guy i just know what i want and i'm
more than willing to kill everything and
everyone to get it
he has no remorse no guilt he is just
single-minded and he is powerful
after being fit by ra he fled the system
lords he went in search of ancient
technology and ancient knowledge and
actually tricked his way into ascension
when the ascended beings realized what
he was they kicked him out but they
didn't kick him out fully he
he was still an incorporal form he still
had the ancient knowledge
or most of it
and
he was basically unkillable
but it was his attack of dakara that was
the most terrifying he was out there to
get a super weapon an ancient super
weapon
that he knew could be reprogrammed to
destroy
all life in the universe
his plan was to literally kill
everything and everyone and repopulate
the universe with
creatures or beings of his own design
and he came
that close to doing it
unlike thanos that believed he was doing
it for the right reasons
anubis was doing it simply because he
could and he wanted to
this was an evil character throughout
and for me the most dangerous bad guy we
have ever seen in sci-fi
thanks if you can think of anybody else
or anyone i've forgotten please leave a
comment tell me all about it please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out and please go join
us on the sidetrack facebook channel the
link is in the description and finally
if you would like to buy this wonderful
t-shirt being modeled by myself and you
know where the quote comes from you can
go buy them
again the link is in the description
thanks very much guys and i'll um see
you next time
[Music]